hello and welcome to the daily climate
show coming up
a risk of droughts leading bodies decide
against water restrictions but stress
people must use water wisely to protect
supplies
a climate disaster more than 6 000
residents evacuate california as a
wildfire the size of san francisco rips
16 acres of land
and future green living saudi arabia
announces plans for a zero carbon city
[Music]
welcome to the daily climate show where
we track the changes happening to our
world hear from those affected and
report on the race for solutions so with
unusually hot weather and minimal
rainfall comes the serious risk of
drought it's not a common occurrence in
the uk but then it's been an unusual
summer dry conditions and little chance
of rain over the next month have
prompted water companies to start
putting drought plans into action with a
strong push to watch how much water
we're using and there's concerns amongst
farmers that this is only the beginning
it's incredibly dry um we are seeing
non-existent grass growth now so the
livestock farmers around me near me are
having to use um winter rations uh you
know what they what they what they've
harvested recently
what they would feed in the winter
they're starting to dip into now because
they've got no grass growth
um that you know the conditions are
tinderbox dry
our correspondent ashna hurinag joins us
now so ashley how much water are we all
using water is collected in the uk in
lots of different ways through rivers
through reservoirs and in underground
sources too but here in the uk we use an
awful lot of it it's estimated that we
actually use 14 billion tons of water
every single day but we don't always
actually use all of it and when it comes
out of our taps or in industry for that
matter because 3.17 billion liters are
lost every single day due to leaks now
all of that supply is threatened by
these hot and dry conditions that we're
getting which is why we're going to
bring in and tell you about the drought
stages
now at the moment the majority of
england
except the north west is sitting within
what's called a prolonged dry weather
spell so we're seeing things like rivers
and reservoirs being withered and some
restrictions are on the horizon
potentially that's been brought on by a
very early dry spring an early dry
summer too the environment agency today
has called a meeting if you like between
their national drought group to discuss
preventative measures they're looking at
agreeing about agreeing things like
reducing the amount of water that
everyone uses
if that does happen we could see if
there is no rainfall for the next two to
three weeks
the environment agency is saying that we
could start to enter that secondary
drought phase as soon as august okay so
are we close then to a host pipe ban
we are keeping an eye on the uk's water
supply that's not just the government
but also the invite the environment
agency specifically this is a map
showing england's rainfall now what's
key to this is that we have had the
driest period between november and june
since 1976.
it looks like the southern the central
areas
in particular are struggling the most
with this the soil is drier than usual
for this time of the year more than 75
percent of groundwater
those river levels in those groundwater
sites are very low there are some rivers
that are exceptionally low namely the
river north tyne in the river cam or a
froome of avon those are kind of hot
spot areas really and the environment
agency and other government bodies are
really watching those river levels
because it's one of our main sources of
supply
if they do start to bring in talk of
drought we may start to see things like
a limit on the amount of
boats or the way that boats are able to
travel through rivers and canals the
water industry may start restricting
non-essential domestic and commercial
use of water and lots of people are
talking about the drought 1976 will that
happen again yeah the great drought 1936
many people will remember this time i
mean how can you not the lands were
cracked the gardens were withered it was
an exceptionally i guess shocking time
because you're used to seeing droughts
in other parts of the world and to talk
about it in the uk and talk about it
right now in the uk obviously is a huge
concern we know that the ground is
warming up and the air around us is
warming up and to think about the
knock-on effect is no doubt concerning
the truth is we are quite far away from
reaching the scenes that we did in 1976
that's that at that time we had a
significant depletion of groundwater
sites but also the supply of water
and it happened because there was no
rain from the december of that year
and the environment agency and people
like the met office say if there is
rainfall within the next two to three
weeks this isn't something that we
necessarily have to worry about but the
crucial thing is how much rain will fall
and if it falls at all if over the next
few weeks we do start to see some rain
which is looking you know it's not
impossible for it to rain over the
summer then we may not see
any form of drought at all but it is
worth having um in the back of our minds
potentially indeed thank you ashna very
much uh time now for the day's other
climate news now
now despite talk of a potential drought
floods in the uk still pose a serious
threat now the government has pledged
100 million pounds to help protect
properties at risk of flooding the
frequently flooded alliance will be used
to improve smaller communities spread
across a smaller area and require a more
complex flood scheme 2 000 flood
defenses are expected to be constructed
across the country by 2027.
now the government is facing fresh legal
action over consent being given to
develop a large north sea gas field
regulators gave the go-ahead in june for
shell to develop the new jackdaw field
of the charity greenpeace who've
launched a legal challenge described the
approval of the site as a scandal and
they claim the government failed to
consider the impact emissions from
burning the gas would have on the
climate
and more than 300 people have been
killed in pakistan as the country
suffers more than five weeks of monsoon
rains and flash flooding now the wet
season runs from july through to
september has called rivers to swell and
has destroyed motorways and bridges and
rain of course is essential to help
crops grow and replenish dams and other
water reservoirs in pakistan
saudi arabia's crown prince has
announced plans for a zero carbon city
which will have vertical layers of
building stretching over a hundred miles
long if successful saudi arabia claimed
nyon will be the first city to be free
of roads cars and any form of emissions
but critics have accused the saudi
arabia prince that the driving force
behind the arm of green washing and
making grand promises about the
environment which are unrealistic
possible
policies even to curb emissions
now eu energy ministers have agreed to
ration national natural gas this winter
to help protect themselves against
supply cuts by russia as moscow
continues its invasion of ukraine now
they agree to a voluntary gas reduction
of at least 15 percent at less than 24
hours after russia's state controlled
energy firm gasprom announced a steep
reduction in gas supplies from wednesday
it comes as eu leaders accuse russian
president vladimir putin of attempting
to blackmail european countries for
supporting ukraine now australia's new
prime minister
has set out how he intends to tackle
climate change as parliament sat for the
first time since he was elected anthony
albanese announced plans for new
legislation that would force australia
to reduce its greenhouse gas emissions
by 43 below 2005 levels by the end of
the decade however it will be a bumpy
road for the new prime minister the
green party have described the target as
modest and and they don't think the
plans are nearly as ambitious enough but
with the political situation as it
stands the bill would need their support
we have our mandate
which is very clear our mandate is for
43
by 2030 we've said of course the nature
of these targets are that it's a floor
not a ceiling but we actually need to
have a plan
to get change you can't just come up
with a figure i will come up with a sort
of thought bubble
our policy is well thought through
it was announced it was campaigned upon
indeed
it received a mandate
now in california thousands of
firefighters have been battling to
contain fires in what's been the latest
example the devastating effects of
climate change across the world now
yosemite is the main area under threat
from fires on both fronts so the oak
fire started on friday near mid pines
and has spread
to over 21
square miles only 10 is currently
contained and the washburn fire 12 miles
east of yosemite is now around 87
contained after burning for nearly two
weeks now currently there are 2 000
firefighters battling the blaze along
with a large number of emergency
vehicles our correspondent joe pike has
been speaking to residents affected
in mariposa county
even before you see what has happened
here you can smell it the ash blowing
through the air the trees that are still
smoking
it is a stark
sobering sight this trail of devastation
wrought
by this fire a charred car park of quad
bikes and sports cars and pickup trucks
all completely destroyed you imagine
that at one stage this was quite
colorful colorful vehicles green trees
but now it's black and gray it's all
monochrome and if you need a sense of
quite how hot it must have been at the
heart of the fire just look at this
trail of what at some point must have
been a molten metal coming from a
charred bicycle
this part of the fire is now under
control even though we still can see
some flames we can still see smoke of
course firefighters have now moved on to
far bigger blazes which continue to move
through thousands of acres of land
if you talk to people at this evacuation
center they saw the signs an intense
drought parched vegetation low humidity
and high heat this has long been a
punishing environment where wildfires
were possible they were a threat but now
climate change has helped make them
almost inescapable
you as a family
feeling in a very real emotive way the
effects of climate change the effects of
all of our behavior
to people
climate change don't affect them they
say you know if he doesn't affect me it
doesn't matter
you know yeah but it's affecting both of
you but it's affecting it's affecting
everybody affecting everybody but they
don't realize this sometimes and it's
gonna affect our grandkids you know
we're supposed to be looking out for
seven generations and we're not
you know we've been um
activists
for a long time
for uh for the earth and climate change
and
uh the way of our people you know
and against the pipelines all that yeah
you know pipelines cutting of trees and
everything else
but people don't respect that
and just before we go is there anything
you want to know about climate change
what confuses you or mystifies you
scan the qr code on your screen right
now to submit your questions to us and
we'll do our best to answer them or you
can go to any of the sky news social
media accounts where you can add your
questions in the comments so do get in
touch well that's all from us today
thanks for watching we'll see you next
time bye